los ministros de defensa de la otan se
reúnen hoy en Bruselas justamente una
semana antes de que se cumpla un año
desde que empezó la invasión de Ucrania
precisamente los países aliados van a
abordar Cómo aumentar la ayuda a Ucrania
más aún cuando el secretario general de
la otan ha pedido más armas más munición
En definitiva más ataques también para
ayudar a Ucrania sobre todo cuando la
ofensiva rusa ya ha empezado en el este
del país pero justamente porque los
países aliados están ayudando
masivamente a Ucrania también se están
Vaciando los depósitos de armas de los
países aliados estaba ser una de las
cuestiones que también van a abordar los
ministros de defensa como aumentar la
producción de armas que sea suficiente
para ayudar a Ucrania pero también para
los propios países que sigan teniendo
los depósitos llenos Según a la otan
ahora mismo el ritmo de gasto actual es
muy superior al de la producción con
tiempos de espera que se pueden dilatar
los dos años para la entrega de tanques
en la reunión de hoy también se va a
abordar Cómo proteger a infraestructuras
críticas Como por ejemplo gasoductos y
evitar casos Como por ejemplo el
Sabotaje del Stream pero también como
proteger más el espacio más aún con los
recientes acontecimientos en que Estados
Unidos y desde Canadá también se han
tenido que abatir varios globos de
supuesto origen chino que trataban de
espiar a estos países según la otan hay
que proteger más en este tipo de casos